welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig today we
have Lindsay peles with us she is
beautiful inside and out you might know
her as an Instagram model a social-media
influencer she worked at Hooters she
sells her calendars she's got a lot
going on for her we talk a lot about the
stigma of being an Instagram model what
that means and actually how hard it is
to do your job and about the one time a
guy offered to give her $500 to pee on a
video for him real juicy conversation on
this episode of not too deep enjoy have
you ever heard of lab-grown
diamonds well lab-grown diamonds are
essentially chemically identical to
natural ones just made in a lab and at
lightbox they've cracked the science to
grow gorgeous stones every time so check
them out at lightbox jewelry dot-com
slash Grace and use code grace for $25
off Lindsay thank you so much for being
here thank you for having me of course
um okay
I've been asking a lot of people this
question and it's not meant to be
negative at all but it's for people that
don't know who you are they might be
discovering you for the first time what
is your deal good cool you know to
figure that out myself honestly truly
yeah I have no idea what my deal is now
I moved to LA like four years ago I was
23 as a bartender somehow I got a
billion Instagram followers are like a
million in six minutes
yeah in six weeks six weeks time I moved
here with like 250 which back then was
insane huge and then I ended up getting
a million in six weeks so I didn't know
you know this wasn't really my plan sure
but I didn't have a major planner
graduated with a history degree I was
bartending yeah so you're from Louisiana
yeah I knew majored in history which is
super cool and also why a good question
truly the true fact is I had a
scholarship an academic scholarship okay
and I was a mass comm major but I worked
full-time so I worked at Hooters of
course yeah the entire time so I was
like a full-blown adult in school
yeah and mass comm is very hard if you
cannot focus on it sure is
it was not so hard for me I was really
really good at it okay so that's my
worst subjects facts people any of it
there's so much murder
I know I'm into like true crime podcast
now you think I would be better at that
yeah no I'm terrible at it okay so you
had this like dual life happening yeah
and well so I had a scholarship and in
four years time it's like I could get
this history degree okay I could ace
history and you know get out of it and I
did so I got my bachelor's in history
okay and then of course I was like what
do I do now I thought about law school
about getting my masters and I loved
bartending and I'm like let me go move
to Vegas or LA okay and see if I can
make a ton of money and just like live a
little
yeah and Vegas was the very obvious
choice but someone said you know if you
could afford to live in both places
where would you go and I said LA and
they said we'll try LA and I did so I
moved here without a job or plan Wow
yeah so you so it all took was for
someone to be like where would you
really ideally love to be yeah there's
this book called who moved my cheese but
that's about fear I'm taking the fear
out of decision so a fear wasn't an
option I would have moved to LA if I
thought I could be pretty enough and
rich enough and cool enough I totally be
in LA I never thought I could
and then now look at you here you are
that's honestly what we're all doing
well just phone clamors and waiting for
someone to call us out the amount that
I've heard people on the podcast
recently talked about like imposter
syndrome and that idea of like someone's
gonna call me out for not being allowed
to be exactly where I'm at right now is
so nuts and like everyone has it yeah
okay I'm very curious about Hooters okay
what was it like working there God so
fun it's so fun it was because I didn't
get to be in a sorority because I had to
pay my bills yeah yeah I was very pissed
about that and a lot of people don't
realize the sororities cost a lot of
money to me money yeah so I didn't get
to do that so Hooters was like we had a
uniform that I was obsessed with my mom
brought me there as a kid really yeah
and I loved like I just loved atmosphere
people were singing they're like you
said happy birthday I just loved the
vibe and so right when I turned 18 I
went to work at Hooters and I worked
there for four years
in a calendar it was a it's actually
very strict really are very women
focused and friendly it was in the
training about how to speak to women
first and offer them everything
basically kiss-ass of any women
customers at any time because everyone
said women pay the bills so they said
you know you had to kiss the ass of any
women that came in yeah and it was
really strict and you had to do a lot of
side work yeah like you had to do a lot
because I worked in other restaurants
and businesses and that was the hardest
the strictest you were graded all the
time it was this very serious situation
interesting though but I mean you would
think I'm sure from the outside the
general consensus is like this is
ridiculous and on the inside you're like
we have a lot of rules and regulations
that I can still tell you how to do the
entire table and I have nightmares like
someone sat and I didn't go bring up
their thing or any appetizers and yeah
oh I was like secret shoppers and all of
it yeah I've worked at every chain
restaurant and same deal but it's like
if you're not at the table with a
coaster on it in 30 seconds yeah you
could be docked pay uh yeah so nuts are
you do you go into Hooters now as an
adult you know I literally was there
last week oh yeah it's so cute there
I've never been I think it's cuz I I ate
there every day for four years in
college it sometimes it's like this is
my home yeah these fried pickles are my
okay you talked about being in the
calendar there what is that
situation is that you get chosen - yeah
really yeah it's so intense and scary
you have to you submit your own pictures
okay just some kind of Hooters God
there's some mystery person you don't
even know where you like mail them off
in a postcard I'm pretty sure mm-hmm and
then they choose some of you from your
franchise so they choose like okay 15
girls per the state of Louisiana okay
and then you all go to the shoot with
the real deal guy okay and if you'll
deal guy comes and you have like maybe
one you know five minutes to get a photo
a perfect shot
yeah I might get in the calendar with
one of those photos or you might not so
it's not even guaranteed yeah so I've
gotten that far and not made
and then one time I made it okay and now
I sell my own calendar so I like [ __ ] on
the whole process that's what's so
interesting to me is that now you've
kind of you've taken this thing and
you've made it your own yeah which is
interesting because I remember growing
up and calendars being a really major
thing even just like and getting kids in
a giant pumpkin calendar that everyone
would go to the stores and in January
they're all 50% off at like Barnes and
Noble and everyone like bought a bunch
for some reason yes and you make your
own calendars now is that still like a
big industry it totally is you know why
cuz it's the best Christmas gift oh it's
a really good price point they're
usually what like 35 40 bucks yeah so
you can get someone a gift of like you
know something to remember all year I
autographed mine is the perfect I mean I
think that's so fun and yet I was a
Hooters fanatic and calendar obsessor I
love playmates in that whole thing yeah
so this is like I've been obsessing
about this from my whole life so when
did you start making your own calendars
three years ago I think was the first
time okay and what's that process like
oh it's so scary because you see
everyone do it any like oh just make a
calendar just take some photos yeah
build it into a calendar yeah and then
he'll know it's like how do i distribute
it I don't know how to mail people stuff
okay how do I change this and how do I
print this but did I get my taxes done
every year is an insane amazing thing
like is a miracle truly like the idea of
mailing a stranger something that they
purchased for me I couldn't do it no
it's asinine and then I'm imagine when
they don't show up oh yeah I have to
kind of come up with the customer
service people and the distributors and
the printers and I full-blown like
creative direct the entire thing so I
find every single location
I choose every outfit I have to hire my
photographer I go back and forth with
the edits which is a painstaking process
yeah last year my calendars were
misprinted twice and I won't accept
anything poor so I'm not sure no we have
to read so you get a really good taste
of business yeah it's like Girl Scouts
it's like my my Girl Scout badge oh yeah
wait so what's your creative process
like like how do you decide on a theme
or how do you decide on whatever like
the aesthetic is gonna be it's so much
fun but well because I have all those
years of staring at the hooters
see what I love yeah and I try to think
what the audience would love so the
first year you know I'm from Louisiana
mm-hmm so I did a Dirty South calendar
oh that makes sense
it was my dream to go home and shoot you
know on Bourbon Street and in the famous
bars and in a swamp on these boats like
I did everything I could ever dream of
and then the second year I'm like what
are my fans want I'm like maybe I'll be
like nearly naked there you go it's
gonna sell like crazy sold like crazy
yeah yes and I said I cut costs and
clothes the whole time yeah your
wardrobe budget was next to nothing so
the last year I did a wet calendar okay
I wanted to be soaking wet so I just in
every way I really did the varsity blues
like whipped cream bikini Oh fine I
rented a dunk tank okay I had a classic
car and did this carwash thing like I
just didn't whole thing all the classic
yeah so next this one coming up I'm
actually shooting in two weeks has
another theme but I don't want to okay
you have to spot I mean this episode
won't go up till November oh well then
it might be our presale oh there you go
Oh should I
I mean if you want it we'll keep it a
locked lip secret yeah sure you know
what no one else could do a better you
know they stole it I'm gonna do the wild
wild west oh yeah fun yes so we are
thinking sexy cowboy jeans yeah are you
doing any heavy fire any you know into
like Will Smith
you are insane that's yeah and there's
this photo of Will Smith where he has
his cowboy hat over his job
I said to my photographer like it if you
don't recreate that you're missing out
he look good and would you Google Wild
West he comes it's like the first
association also like West world any
like cyborg a type of stuff that gets
expensive
yeah that's special effects making yeah
that goes into a whole new world that's
so cool I had no idea that calendars
were still like a major thing yeah it's
fun how does family feel about it
they're supportive or they just kind of
like she's doing it got it first thing I
could not stand anything I was up to
they just thought it was insane and the
first time I got paparazzi hardcore my
mom totally changed her I posted it on
her Facebook Yahoo News and MSN
IME and someone full-blown paparazzi the
first time like through the bushes oh
wow yeah me drunk at the pool yeah okay
bandwagon but does she own any of the
calendars she has some my dad has some
that's great yeah my dad held the
reflector for the Dirty South in the
background literally holding the
reflector oh so nice I mean if that's
not support I know what is okay so you
so you're starting out with social media
in Louisiana then came out here what
were you doing before Instagram was a
major thing oh so he's bartending sure
you've bartending yeah were you still
doing like social media he's still like
dabbling in that overall I'd moved here
with like 250,000 I was making $0 I was
just posting selfies and I was getting a
kick every time and go up a thousand
sure I'm having fun yeah and when I
moved here I found a job on Craigslist
Oh to Barton at the Avalon okay which
atom have you been Avalon I've heard of
it but for people that don't live here
like how would you describe that place
it is an iconic music venue and a
concert hall so they do events and then
they have like a club night but it's so
wild dan Aykroyd is one of the owners
but Bruno Mars's worked there Skrillex
has worked there Ryan Gosling was a DJ
wow there's so much history in this spot
that I happened to pick up off of
Craigslist off of Craigslist yeah and so
I worked there for months I moved here
in October I worked there till about
February March and at one point someone
was paying me 300 dollars to post a
protein shake okay and at my bar
although I made a ton of money I just
split it so I was you know at the bar I
had to split it with the other
bartenders I was very pissed about it
they still know this I'm still friends
with some of them but it was like I was
just handing out donations I hated it
and so I was like if I make $300 doing
this selfie mm-hm and I go to the bar
for a seven to make the same thing maybe
my times better
Bente market on the selfie if I do the
math here yeah and I called and quit my
job okay and then I called and tried to
ask for it back right away because I
said what and they were like Lindsey
think about it and then I never had to
get a job again Wow yeah so how do you
so because one there's so much negative
perception of being like an Instagram ah
yeah and you're very intelligent human
being and I'm sure that you have to like
butt up against these people that
constantly perceive you and assume
certain things yeah yeah but then to
like start having success in that world
like how do you start filtering in like
the requests that come in for business
yeah that's just crazy hard and I miss
all of it I miss half of it it took a
really long time you're doing it all
yourself for the especially in the
beginning yeah it takes a long time in
any Hollywood I feel like environment
yeah to find a team and to figure it out
and I moved here at 23 so my brain
wasn't even done developing yeah yeah
dumb you are 23 oh god we think we're
genius then we look back and I'm like a
[ __ ] idiot so dumb I don't know how I
did anything right I don't know how I'm
alive now and so it took you know the
first year I moved here and I was like
WTF the second year I was like what am I
doing with my life the third year I kind
of gotta focus
mm-hmm and I realized kind of where my
goals were and everything happened that
way and then you know the team started
to form and I started to figure out how
to make money yeah and once you figure
out a little it all kind of comes sure
and you get it together but it's crazy
with that Instagram model kind of
stereotype you know everyone on
Instagram is modeling it's just said a
few of us are getting paid for it that's
such a great way to put that that's
absolutely breaking yeah yeah yeah
every selfie you put up there is exactly
the same that you're doing yeah you're
just holding a protein shake yeah I
would like to pay you for that yeah and
be happy for me I mean three jobs is
bartending well that's the interesting
thing is I think people can look at your
Instagram account and like scroll
through and go oh I have this girl peg
you know exactly who she is
yeah and then you learn if it takes it
takes you 30 seconds to learn you have a
degree you worked your ass off you came
out here with the same dream or
aspirations that everyone else
came out here with yeah and that what
you're doing isn't any less than what
everyone else is trying to hustle and do
yeah literally it's so bonkers is there
a company that you wish you could work
with that you haven't worked with yet oh
that's a good question I've had it from
my vision board for me it's more about
like publications like I want to be on
the cover of a maxim one day you know
that kind of thing but I mean as far as
brands god there's got to be something
that comes to my mind is just completely
but you have vision boards using very
vision board II honestly my vision board
would be more cell phone businesses you
know within time actually invested in a
restaurant recently oak women-owned so
I'd like to expand in my own company
situations your entrepreneurialship
yeah yeah that's awesome very cool also
it makes sense that your vision board
based if your based on Instagram which
is ultimately its own vision board yeah
I love the vision boards who do you like
who's your go-to followed on Instagram
that you look at all the time is there
anyone that you check in on for better
or worse oh I love my friend Anna Sheree
I don't know if I've ever seen her no
huge but she works for this but like she
has this crazy body uh-huh she and her
husband own a gym and they worked their
ass off like she has every brand her
photo shoots are like impeccable your
styling is amazing there's just so much
work I know that goes into your business
and they're a team with it so I'm just
obsessed like I go to her for
inspiration like how can I be better at
what I do cuz she does a really great
job as far as like social media yeah but
then I'm obsessed with you know other
people in real life I don't know I'm a
huge lizzo fan oh yeah and then I have
the supermodels I stalk like I love
Rachel Mortensen most people don't know
who that is but she's a hot girl like I
just had my weird quirks in favori yeah
I call him everyone honestly that's
great that's very cool is there someone
that's followed you that has been the
most surprising like celebrity or
notable person well I got to meet Erika
Jayne on a podcast oh my god Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills Erika Jayne
literally the
I met her I randomly had no idea she was
gonna be at this podcast I did died on
the inside I'm a huge Bravo fan yeah
Erika Jayne fan and she ended up being
so sweet they asked me to do her music
video are expensive what yes so if you
ever watch it I'm pillow fighting her
into bed for so much frickin fine and
she's so nice and like she'll check up
on me out of the blue she's like oh I
saw you on this or she'll be like how
are you doing today like you know just
like little thing just thoughtful are so
big to me and I'm like oh she's she's
also I think a really great
representative of that whole universe of
like the way she looks on the outside is
very different than she's like a badass
boss [ __ ] that like handles her
business and has great relationships and
that but from the outside you like write
her off it's just like a pretty face I'm
pretty mess and then you're like no
there's way more substance there's
there's way more thought there's way
more like she's her plan she has a plan
it's not just all accidental I love it I
want to be a miniature
I mean you basically are sleepovers but
I don't want to be like the first one to
ask
[Laughter]
I don't want to adult woman to ask
here's okay she listens to this episode
of the podcast and then you get a text
that's like I accept because I'm scared
okay we're gonna take a quick break when
we get back I have some more questions
for you then we have some Internet
questions it's gonna be real fun we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
too deep today we have support from a
company that won't stop supporting you
I'm talking about third love third love
designs bras with breast size and shape
in mind for a perfect fit and premium
feel hands down the most comfortable bra
that you'll own they have straps that
don't slip they have tag list labels
not to mention lightweight super thin
memory foam cups that mold to your shape
every customer also get this has 60 days
to put their bra to the test if you
don't love it you return it and then
third-level wash it and donate it to a
woman in need they support charities in
their local San Francisco Bay Area and
across the u.s. so even if it's not for
you it's for someone else and you're
doing a great deed by just supporting
this company they know that there's a
perfect bra for everyone and this is
coming from someone that wears a
basically an ace bandage sports bra
every day I absolutely love their bras
and they're offering you guys 15% off
your first order if you go to third love
comm slash grace go find your perfect
fitting bra get 15% off your first
purchase again third love th I are the
LOV comm slash grace for 15% off today
if there is something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self esteem and more they will connect
you with a professional counselor in a
safe and private online environment and
get help at your own time at your own
pace anything you share is confidential
it's convenient you can schedule secure
video or phone sessions as well as chat
and text with your therapists and if for
some reason you're not happy with your
counselor they you can request a new one
and they'll give one to you a new one at
anytime for no additional charge and
best of all it's affordable and you will
get 10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so get started at
better help calm slash grace
fill out a questionnaire so that they
can help assess your needs and match you
with the counselor that you will love
again better help calm slash grace great
for a second Lindsay just casually
dropped that she hung out with the Gorga
yeah which if you guys don't know Joe
Gorga it's and why am i blanking the
wife's name is melissa gorga from Real
Housewives of New Jersey my homestay
yeah so I feel very akin to this whole
franchise
I'm also Bravo obsessed me too wait so
what was it like hang out the Gorgas so
cool one of our mutual publicists mom
actually what did we do we went to a
Lakers game like finally they were like
you want to go the Lakers game with the
core guys and when that request comes
and you don't turn it down I like let's
go so we went out and they were super
cute and recently I had an appearance
and Atlantic City uh-huh and they were
filming for the Real Housewives I knew
oh god it was amazing I totally scared
my way in I got to go in fully like oh I
took a picture with Frank and Dolores Oh
Dolores and like she said they knew my
dog's name oh my god died I was like are
you kidding amazing amazing I mean every
Bravo fan I was like it was a funny oh I
hope that you're just this little like
seed planted and every franchise now
that you're in like the background that
like all the major fans are like she's
the through line I'm gonna wait there's
one scene yeah I don't I don't know if I
could spoil it but I'm sitting right
next to them and there's no way I'm not
I want to be so badly like a little
Easter egg in the background of those
scenes but I know I would ruin it I know
I'd look like directly into the camera
or I'd be too giddy and too overexcited
that they'd be like I get this freak out
of here yes distracting from the fight
that's happening you get hired okay oh
god I mean I wish I wish
is there any reality show that you would
actually be a participant on yeah yeah
yeah I mean I do a lot of them I
actually turned down a lot of dating
ones cause people always do yeah the
date that people they're usually so
young the
dating ones it's just people I would
never date honestly and it feels like
those have more opportunity to like edit
you in a bad way yeah
and I feel like that would be more of
like a stressful thing totally yeah
totally but no I don't definitely would
you do any of the like survivors would
you do any of the like Amazing Race or
any of the like what else am I even
thinking of Oh like naked and afraid
aren't you in a ministry all that show i
watch that show with my man and we have
just died it's insane
how they you know what they don't tell
you when though chicks are on their
period right I think that's not fair
well we looked it up I went a little
deep diving on it and apparently like
that when they they try to schedule it
supposedly so that it's not on the cycle
of the woman that's in that episode but
if it is that the production provides
them with like whatever sanitary things
they need I feel like your primitive
survival rating should go like way up
right because you're working with way
less yike you have no tylenol you have
no idea or energy nothing for cramps
like yeah you're still surviving amazing
yeah I just think that they should be
really free but that's my own personal
issue no I would never do that shower at
literally died of a heart attack yeah I
would do uh Celebrity Big Brother in the
UK you would yes cuz my ex did it a few
times really just I just feel like over
there I'd be like whatever I did over
there wouldn't count yeah that's the one
I haven't gotten super into Big Brother
except I watch the celebrity version
that happened with like Ross Matthews
was on and I thought that was
interesting but I just didn't know
enough about like the dynamics of the
show and either like how it works I have
no idea I still I didn't realize that
the house is literally against the
studio that they shoot with the audience
in it like it's their physical yeah yeah
right I was like that's where they're
living and also just the idea that
there's a live feed camera that you can
check in on the internet the whole time
makes me feel so and so much anxiety for
them it's pretty gross but I think you
should do it okay so let's get into some
social media stuff do you have any
social
host that you think could definitely be
used against you during a trial based on
your jury duty experiences absolutely
okay what are your jury duty experiences
oh my god I was on a jury
okay and when I was in college they made
me be on a jury and so I experienced
about like a week and a half of actual
court litigation situation yeah what was
that experience like you know boring a
lot more boring she thought what a way
to sleep at one point in the the little
stands but it was but I learned a lot
like I learned a ton there's only so
much you can know about how you know
suing people and that kind of process
works and being involved in it you
really get it yeah so I I was I enjoyed
the process and I thought as a Good
Samaritan for bringing my best and you
know no that's good I'm a matter
technically have jury duty in like a
week and I have to try and get out of
because I won't be in town and I don't
know how it works I'm just thinkin vini
avoiding it yeah but I feel like I will
be chosen if I go and then I'm gonna
feel that pressure of having to be it
really yeah like dedicated to listening
to every single detail of the case could
you have to assume if this were me right
what I want someone like me on the stand
and I probably would right yeah and a
jury of your peers is kind of a sketchy
situation huh cuz our peers are wack
Bret and unknown wants to be there no
one wants to do this yeah like maybe one
in every 100 persons like once to
actually have this responsibility yeah
but I feel like for the most part none
of us do know it was a week and a half
about yeah something like that
and like all day long every day all day
long it's like a 7:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
situation you get paid like six dollars
yeah I don't think you'd be like here's
a bag lunch or something it was really
wild but yeah but I learned a lot I did
learn about how things can and will be
used against you in a court of law why I
will never forget what I've learned and
I also won't forget like the links that
both parties will go through to disprove
and prove their point it's kind of
incredible it's you know if you remember
when recently everyone was posting on
Instagram I don't want my stuff used
against me in a court of law and they're
reposing this like idiotic nobody saw
you didn't post it I never know I don't
know what this is no no I'm like I'd
hardly post anything Thanks
substantial and it's true
it was recent it was this like Facebook
drawn up page and it was like that
people thought was like an official Doc
and it Betty they would get out of any
of their stuff being used against them
that's literally what it said it was so
painful the amount of people that we
shared it Wow it was so painful but also
the people that are we sharing it have
very obvious like skeletons in their
closet are you talking [ __ ] about in
your messages who cares if someone goes
in your stuff Wow
but that is so interesting to see
firsthand it has that changed or
affected the way that you approach your
social media are you much more like
careful and conscious about like what
you're posting no I mean yeah I think I
might ride to be a careful person like
when I do insult people back on Twitter
or on Instagram I don't use anything
gendered and I don't use slurs and I
don't use anything that could be taken
the wrong way I just like equal
opportunity where it's like dumbass and
loose I mean that's I actually use the
word dork all the time ya know that I
saw and I was like that's one of my
favorite words to use because for some
reason to the right person it's the most
cutting insult of all time even though
in the grand scheme of life it's a very
dumb like light term yeah yeah I'm
really fascinated by the way that you
approach people that come for you on
social media did you try not to do that
is it something that you're like I can't
not this person's being absolutely
ridiculous and I need to stand up for
myself yeah it depends on the platform
Instagram I don't at all really
sometimes I have I have especially have
if I've noticed a person was a parent or
a teacher does that really infuriates me
yeah a person is just a responsibility
to other you yeah that one drives me
nuts and I've actually sent messages to
people's principals their jobs stuff
like that if I'm bored and it's the
right time of day yeah but it's I mean
that is I in my mind that there are
situations in which yeah that makes
sense because you're human they're human
like the fact that they think they can
sit down and say incredibly hurtful
things and it doesn't affect you or
doesn't like get to you or that you
don't see it is
outrageous to me it's wild Twitter I
like it a lot more mm-hmm and I had this
discussion with my boyfriend now cuz
he's like why do you do this like it
just puts you why would you want to
engage with him why do you do that and
I'm like look some people like me mm-hmm
I consider myself an intellect and I
like to flex my brain sometimes yeah I
like the take down in a hundred and
fourteen characters it's fun for me I
don't know it's actually fun
yeah I don't get upset like I really
don't like my heart's not racing on my
chest like every now and then it's just
a little bit of fun yeah and I like it
and I like to tell people that they
wronged somebody well it also feels like
people a lot of times they just want the
attention from you and they're provoked
they're like poking at you trying to get
something out of you and I think have
you found that people are genuinely
surprised when you like respond to them
from an intellectual point of view yeah
they really enjoy it yeah that's what my
Twitter is it's really a lot of
comebacks and stuff like that because
people are just like they didn't expect
me to speak like that right like that
I'm just waiting a face yeah Snooki is
great on her Twitter she's actually who
I you know tried to be like for a long
time because people would write her
terrible stuff and she would just agree
to it or she was really clever yeah yeah
about how she handled it and she has a
ton of flowers and even Erika Jaynes
shuts people down all the time Sanna
know at some point you just have to
because otherwise you just keep the door
open for people to like continuous yeah
I like try to hurt you totally in some
way okay are you still doing your
podcast
yeah but not as often as I should okay
so what is if you had any of your or
let's say in the grand scheme of the
world if you could have anyone as a
permanent co-host who would you want to
see that's hard because I am because my
brain is all over the point like I want
someone funny but I want someone that we
can talk about aliens and get like I
don't know he was appropriate for that I
still have it because if I found him or
heard they'd be on but I'm just not sure
yeah who has the same interests as me
all the way and what's the part like the
podcast is that you get into very deep
conversations about things yeah kind of
that's what it turned into at first I
wanted to do like pop culture and the
time of my life and it just wasn't it
didn't not work but then over time I was
like I just like hearing about real
people and stories and people
who just interests me and if you don't
then just don't really want to yeah I'm
not gonna do like a fake combo right
but most people have these deeper
stories that most people don't know
about and I really enjoyed yeah I think
that's great
do you believe in aliens you know I kind
of am one of the thing that we might be
in a simulation so aliens may be of our
own being like they might be like us but
they might be controlling me like a sim
yeah that's true you know and it's hard
to get too deep into that thought
because it'll make you crazy yeah I
totally but I appreciate my aliens if
they're running the show because I've
had a really good time yeah my aliens of
my FBI agents I have general
appreciation for both of you these keep
me safe thank you okay what is smart
house oh my god smart house is the best
Disney Channel original movie about I
don't know what this is oh my god so
dizzy is coming back but they're like
streaming platform okay they've ever
left anywhere but they're having a
streaming platform so their original
movies I'm assuming are coming back oh
and smart house is like the all-time
best Disney Channel original movie
what is the oh it's dope this kid wins a
house this is like robot in the house
can make you a smoothie and the house
can like clean up your mess oh gosh can
throw a house party and but then the
house becomes like they want to be your
real mom and everything yeah oh it
becomes too intelligent
you got some motions yeah serious this
is whoa that is a very I mean I should
check that out it's the best when did
that movie come out probably like 1998
and that's super ahead of its time I
feel like that's true also you love
Lifetime movies no I don't okay they are
wild you are watching one the other day
and I think you were tweeting out like
what the actual premise was dude and it
looked like a mad lib sentence that got
filtered and I was not even exaggerating
so I put on my time because I was doing
other things something that I put
something lighter here background noise
yes and in the side eye or
like the background of what I was seeing
some girls dad was hitting on her then
she was banging her uncle
then someone died of a lion attack was
proposed to the guy she was proposed to
slept with her cousin it was just
everything at once it was like they
threw in everything into the the one
movie oh my god what I feel like the
Lifetime movies become a parody of
themselves at some point like what's
every possible insane storyline that we
can put in here insane I miss those like
Lisa Rinna days where she was doing this
like - that's right she was a movies oh
God
I mean you I mean there's still time you
could do it I would like to think you'd
be more chill to read the script before
I agree I think it could be really good
um okay here's a question I'm really
curious about because you work with a
bunch of different photographers on all
of your shoots what to you is one of the
most important things a photographer can
do to make you feel comfortable as
someone in front of the camera mmm this
is a good question I mean honestly I
feel like it's not telling people what
to do somewhat like I don't know
sometimes people will tell you know what
to wear or take off this shirt or do
that everyone should always be polite
like do you want to do this you feel
comfortable doing this just those like
nice people I don't know it's nice when
you separate yeah yeah there are totally
creeps out there and they're totally not
creeps out there yeah it's just a little
tough and your overall aura will give it
away if you're a perv and an [ __ ] or
not yeah and if you get that icky
feeling if you're shooting with someone
they're an icky person shut it down
totally yeah how do you yeah how do you
like that your photographers that you
work with how do you do like how do you
hire someone um now I do my best cuz I
have word of mouth and I've been working
with so many people for so long but
there have been times when I've I've
seen people that have worked with
someone and then met them and they were
totally creepy but I'm really good at
like telling someone to f off really
that's really like yeah drawing a line
totally I think that's a huge thing so
I'm sure a lot of people can get caught
up in like I guess I'll just roll with
this until like it's done situation yeah
that's sad and scary yeah that is scary
yeah but I'm glad that you're saying
like it's okay to say you know what
we're good I'm good all the time yeah
and it's so funny when you say that how
the mood all changes I'm like no I'm not
gonna do that I'm okay yeah that's like
what you just actually yeah like nuts
but that's I think really important to
hear okay we're gonna take one last
break and when we get back we have a
bunch of Twitter questions for you if
you do not mind entertaining those we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
high and mighty is putting hanging into
your hands hanging can be overwhelming
we're talking about hanging things on
the wall decorating your house something
I love to do and think I'm capable of
though then when push comes to shove not
so much the second you have to get out a
tool it's now a project so your favorite
art gets left on the ground and floating
shelves are bought but never put up and
if you guys have watched any of my
youtube videos I've attempted multiple
times to put up shelves and it does not
work out I think I can I think I can and
then I can't and then I can't but guess
what lose the anxiety with
high-and-mighty
you can hang without needing a single
tool you just place push hang and it's
up they offer strong and easy to install
hanging products like wall hangers
decorative hooks and floating shelves
their hangers hold up to a hundred and
twenty-five pounds so there's no such
thing as something that's too heavy to
hang and they have floating shelves that
come with their own level and install in
just minutes this stuff is absolutely
wonderful for the not so professional
DIY home decor domestic goddess and all
of us like I truly identify with so get
your hands on the full line of products
at design to be stuck up calm again
designed to be stuck up calm and right
now they're giving away some products to
try just visit high-and-mighty on
facebook or instagram at designed to be
stuck up and enter to win support for
today's episode comes from bareMinerals
the creators of clean beauty
purity in formulation and uncompromising
performance have always been the guiding
principles of bareMinerals because they
believe that makeup and skin care should
make your skin better not just better
looking what a concept and this has been
their philosophy since they began the
clean beauty revolution in 1995 with
their best-selling original foundation
which offers creamy lightweight
buildable coverage that's naturally
luminous you don't have to sweat to look
naturally luminous anymore the clean
formula is made from five good for skin
ingredients guess what they're all
minerals including non-chemical SPF
protection makeup so pure you can sleep
in it and it actually improves your skin
over time
sign me up it's everything your skin
needs and nothing it doesn't because for
bare minerals to be clean without
compromise means good for skin formulas
with proven performance and like every
bare minerals product it's 100% cruelty
free and better yet both the original
and matte loose powder foundations are
available in 30 shades so upgrade to the
clean beauty products by using their
foundation finder at bare minerals calm
to find your perfect match first time
customers will get 15% off when use the
promo code not too deep that's bare
minerals calm promo code not too deep
for 15% off your first purchase bare
minerals the power of good okay before
we get into these Twitter questions I'm
going to ask you the two questions asked
every single guest that's on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti
act oh my god it's like an [ __ ] where
is a good spaghetti it's your choice
it's like I can be celebratory it can be
hurtful it's whatever you would like I
don't know the appropriate answer is
like the first thing off my head is
Hitler yeah I just feel like he needs
more than spaghetti that it can be the
warning flag
well yeah I mean that's not the question
I'm asking cold spaghetti probably how
about my first high school boyfriend
that's great he's a loser
there you go it's not against the law
that we know of at this point
okay the other question is to tell us
your worst pant [ __ ] story or close
call but you can only tell us in three
words or small phrases so for example
mine is college jogging front lawn hmm
poisoned crawfish boil immediately and
that sounds like a heavy metal band
I saw Def Leppard two days ago how was
that metal was that like a bucket list
thing no but we just like scam tickets
in Vegas and I see Def Leppard is so
funny that's so fine I'm sure that crowd
must have been amazing
the crowd was fun they were really
getting you know those those guys have
been around for a long time yeah how old
are they now gotta be like 70 60 maybe
yeah maybe
still I mean kudos to them still wearing
flat one of them had six pack abs like
it was just insane
yeah thought they're awesome that sounds
super fun okay let's give into these
Twitter questions someone is asking what
is the key thing in your life that keeps
you inspired and motivated who um the
key thing in my life that keeps me
inspired and motivated is honestly my
intuition really yeah I kind of have a
strong intuition and I I know the end I
know like the end goals of everything so
getting through day to day is just
remembering that the end will be the
same no matter how [ __ ] the day is
like my end will be the same it always
is I just my intuition has never failed
me interesting yeah I've never heard
that perspective before that's very cool
yeah what about Tosh I love Tosh there's
a second inter know I love Tosh Tosh is
your dog yeah it's hashas my dog Tosh is
my one I'm orky oh I mean what a great
tagline that is a what that marquee I
know he's about seven oh he's an old man
yeah we'll see that's why I'm gonna stop
saying he's like he's gonna be seven and
never older yeah
but we're at that same age cuz I'm 28 so
people go oh you don't look that alone
so now they're doing it to my dog like
oh he doesn't like that old write on the
same page how when did you get him I got
him when I was 21 in and when I was
going to school at LSU uh-huh I was a
sophomore in college I'm pretty no I
must have been a junior I'm I said I
don't know exactly that look I just woke
up and he was there but yeah totally I
wanted a cat but then I knew that like
50/50 chance of cat wouldn't be down
with me oh yeah we were just talking
about cats before you got here and a lot
of people in this room have very strong
opinions about class Melissa hates them
very much but wait so how did you how
did you guys come into being together
well so I wanted a cat and everyone was
like no you should like a dog will
definitely love you like a dog and I had
a customer at the bar I worked out
uh-huh Hey oh you want a dog I'll go get
you a dog Nana totally came got me a dog
wait what yeah I know that was so young
she's stupid to know about like rescuing
and everything right yeah in Louisiana -
they just don't care like they're just
not even a conversation so I bought well
he bought this dog so the customer
bought the dog for you yeah
did you so when they show up with the
dog are you like what we vetted herself
okay I know this breeder I'll buy this
dog for you okay and then literally like
I wind got Tosh out of this like random
ratchet breeders Louisiana which is how
it was like rescuing him truly Wow yeah
it is like it what um along those lines
has there been any other bonkers things
that like patrons have like gotten for
you or requests or like wanted to do for
you Oh God there was one guy at Hooters
uh-huh
he didn't tell me directly but he told
this other waitress so there's other
waitress she was like a little older she
had kids she was like making cash I'd
shoot him there to hustle yeah and she
came out to meet you guys
Lindsey um you know that guy that's
always in here like my regular he always
gives me like five hundred bucks a day
and then uh I was like yeah she goes if
you want to he'll pay you to go pee in
the bathroom and if you just film like
where you
I'll give you five we walk the way she
said it's so nice I was like you
couldn't beat me because you know damn
well that she just peed in the bathroom
so I was like you know I have to pee
like I'm fine wow this is a business
yeah I'm like you can have this too if
you want it yeah which is why I did it
I mean it should have either way good
for you um and for her and Wow okay
interesting but you got a dog I did I
got a dog okay someone to know what's my
special purpose like mine or yours I
think they're asking are there [ __ ] it's
right better tweets from do good stuff
1993 that is such a fun name yeah
as long as it's meaning it's
well-intentioned to not bad yeah good
stuff well my purpose I think in life
I'd like to be you know a liaison to
kind of I know we live in a really
polarizing comment climate politically
so Louisiana you grew up with one type
of group and then living in a city like
LA in New York it's another and I have a
college education that can really help
me understand both mm-hmm and I just
feel like to be the opposite of a
tommy'll Aaron would be ideal I love the
idea of teaching people how to be
empathetic yeah and maybe understand one
another and to do that in a way that
isn't so angry yeah I think I have that
potential so long-term in my life that
would be my goal that's awesome yeah
that's really aspirational to want to
like create bridges and have
conversations yeah that'd be my goal
yeah especially for someone like you
that I'm like we said faces so much
stereotypical like assumption constantly
they'd be like talk to me like a human I
want to talk to you like a human yeah
that's all I want
yeah I think that can happen stay true
someone's no thoughts on lover by Taylor
Swift how does it go the new at the new
album the new Taylor Swift album I
didn't hear it it's there use your
thoughts on it who other than Def
Leppard who are your musical go - oh
well I'm obsessed with Liz oh but I was
like two years ago
you're an old school friend yeah
I heard that her music a long time ago
so it's really played out the stuff now
cuz you get so older to me and I got to
see her at the Spotify event really
caring people how is the habit of I love
Liz oh right now I loved OG cat okay I
don't know who that is it's a fine
person it's a person it's a rapper a
female rapper and she is like fun fun
fun songs oh that's great yes so that's
how I'm obsessed with right now but I
bounce everywhere yeah I keep me
obsessed with anyone at any time
very cool Oh someone's to know if you
stand Rihanna of course I mean who does
it naturally I love the pictures
circulating right now of when Lady Gaga
came out in the meat dress yeah I'd be
amazed and everyone looks like they're
just totally disgusted Miyata has like a
big smile the Rihanna in that crowd oh
if you google image search Rihanna
leaving restaurants with wine she just
leaves restaurants it's just all
paparazzi photos of her just with her
wine glass walking to her car and I'm
like this is the coolest thing anyone
could do I'm gonna take this to God
so yeah someone's know what's the best
gift you could give to someone you don't
really know I Lindsay Payless 2020
calendar there you go autographs better
signed sealed delivered
wait so you autograph all of them I do
yeah thanks forever are you venturing
into other varieties of merch yeah I
think I will and I might I've been
talking about it with a few people we've
considered you know athletic wear yeah I
have a range of graphic tees I would
like to do you have fun sayings but you
know we'll see see ya the how far in
advance do you plan out your photos like
for Instagram okay like day of or is it
like I have everything mapped out for
the next two months no I wish I would
that organize mine is totally day out
really yeah it's really hard I'm not
good I don't actually don't post every
single day I just post every few days oh
dang and so how do you do you edit all
your photos yourself no but sometimes
okay yeah I added a lot of them myself
what's your go-to editing obviously
facetune faced oh okay soon as life ya
can do their videos now to what I feel
like that is where it's a little far can
I get sketchy I really
that's gonna be a little scandalous
that's totally catfishing I yeah I think
I opened face to him one time and I was
like this is too much power I don't like
it and then I close it out deleted it
off my phone oh my god you crazy I've
got the VIP preview like 35 but it makes
sense that's a business write-off for
you no okay someone asks how do you feel
when people can't get past your image
and would rather perceive you as dumb or
shallow I usually feel that someone's
ignorance is their own stuff you know um
it's really I can't be a teacher for
everyone at every moment yeah but I have
to assume that it's just some version of
misogyny internalized misogyny because I
think if you look at me if for some
reason platinum hair and large boobs
makes you feel a certain way then I
assume that's because I'm hyper feminine
and I assume you have a problem with
femininity and I don't you know I don't
dress down or dress how people would
want me to yeah cuz I actually don't
care like I will even if you think I'm
hyper feminine I'm down with being me
and I'm gonna do what I want yeah and so
yeah so it's actually I'm not really do
it you know I don't know I just live how
I want I think I mean that's great
because I can feel like you could go one
of two ways either you become really
combative against people or you become
just like very scared of everyone and
not like you don't give yourself
permission to be yourself
yeah if people if I I would actively be
hiding my body if I wore what other
people wanted yeah a lot of the times my
necklines are the same and my fits I
mean you know the outfits are the same I
don't actually shop at the horse store I
don't even know where sorry I don't even
know where they think I'm getting the
clothes I get yeah you know it's just
crazy I mean everyone has things that
they do to make themselves feel
confident yeah and it's so bizarre to me
when people judge negatively someone's
version of confidence yeah it's very I
think that like you said it's just
projection of insecurities that people
are like that person's confident well I
want to knock them down a peg yeah
because I'm not confident
it's so weird and it's so hard in that
era of like self-love and you want to
uplift everyone but we want to leave
certain people out yeah we want you to
love yourself but only to a point in
which I feel like I'm better than you
yes
oh it's very confusing the Internet's so
fun okay last question before we wrap up
someone's asking favorite grandma story
Oh
hmm well my grandma I got a pogo stick
huh great and my grandma is like 95
pounds and she just jumped on my pogo
stick and busts her ass in the garage
and I just never forget how she really
got on a pogo stick out like that's very
bold yeah it was wild we should break
anything which is even more impressive
like fell down completely didn't break
any was she doing it for entertainment
or did you would like happen to catch
her by herself it was totally like she
wanted to try it yeah Lindsay thank you
for being here this has been super fun
before you go every guest that's on the
podcast we create a fortune cookie a
personalized fortune cookie you know
what it says I know what it says but if
you would like to open it and find out
what it says you are free to do so
oh I thought there was no fortune yeah I
got asked a prom in a fortune cookie you
did huh that's cute no this is not that
question okay I'm scared
there is a company that will for $14,000
take your ashes and compress them into a
synthetic diamond to be set and jewelry
for a loved one with that in mind we
have a favor to ask you
yep we can take it offline but we wanted
to plant the seed wait you want me to
give you my ashes ourselves we need you
to hock this on your Instagram so we can
make some money yeah like that I do have
a quick question are there like things
that you draw the line like what's been
the weirdest like request someone like
through social media has been like I'll
pay you to promote this oh my god
they'll ask for everything I'm sure I
mean the biggest line drawn is like
people offer money for sex yeah I'm not
even I'm really actually truly not doing
that like I don't know it's been four
years and you're following me like
there's I've never had a rolls-royce yet
like you know
I don't know how they're not putting two
and two together they don't do that so
that would definitely be where I draw
the line but I also try not to post
about them I try not to post about
smoking mm-hmm cigarettes or weed yeah
yeah yeah I try not to also post about
drinking but I will if you pay me you
have morals and you're a hustler at the
same time that's great
Lindzi where can people find you if they
don't know and where can people get the
calendar and see what you're up to all
that you can follow me at Lindzi pelos
on Instagram Twitter the works and then
my calendar will be available at Lindsay
Palace Co in a month or so probably time
you listen to this amazing and make sure
you're following her because we don't
know what she's gonna do but it's gonna
be big coming up thank you so much for
being here we'll see you guys next time
on not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep
2deep whatever struggles you are facing
from depression and anxiety to trauma
and grief better help can connect you
with a professional counselor in a safe
and private online environment it's
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and anything
you share is completely confidential and
it's affordable and you'll get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace so get started by going to better
help calm slash grace fill out a
questionnaire get matched with the
counselor your love today not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa Dumont's
writing by Diane Kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]